okay here we go going in now see the
Vision Pro
no photos no video no so I have good
news and bad news the good news I did
get to try out Apple's new mix reality
headset bad news Apple wouldn't let us
film me wearing it
thus we're here they did let us film the
headset on a table roll that footage
[Music]
but yes I did get to spend 30 minutes
wearing the headset which is really
focused on bringing digital objects into
your real world
roll footage from the keynote in games
on a giant screen surrounded by spatial
audio
connect with people as if you're sharing
the same space I got to see a few of
those Demos in the headset which is by
far the best AR VR headset I've ever
used but it's still a headset
let me take you through it
from here
let's start with what it's like to wear
this thing honestly it felt like apple
stuck a giant Apple watch
to my head in a good way the sock-like
headband was easy to put on and adjust
the size with the knob oh look Tim Cook
showed up not wearing the headset for
the first 15 minutes of the demo I
couldn't believe how comfortable it was
far Cozier than the metaquest pro or the
quest 2.
a lot of that is because the battery
lives in a pack that's attached to the
headset behold battery pack footage
honestly the battery which is said to
last only two hours was pretty light and
easy to fit in my back pocket but it's
still a lot of tech on your face by the
end of the demo the top of my nose and
forehead started to feel the weight
here's a photo of me when I took it off
[Music]
I guess this is why so much of the
footage from Apple is of people alone in
their homes with this facial Cinema that
transforms any space like this apartment
you have a gorgeous screen you can
adjust to the perfect size Apple says
that discomfort was because it only had
limited sized light seals which fit the
headset to your face there will be more
options when the device is available
early next year
okay so what's it like to look through
this thing pretty insane especially
compared to other headsets out there
apple is really focusing on blending the
digital world with your real world and
you can really toggle between a VR like
experience where you're in a virtual
world and an AR like experience where
digital objects show up in your real
world
spin the digital Crown one way and
you'll see more of the real world spin
it the other and you see less
press on the button and you get taken to
the home screen and it again really
works like that even better looking at
the real world looks crisp and clear
unlike the metaquest pro where things
can look rainy but going back and forth
between AR and VR did make me feel a
little bit queasy by the end of the demo
it wasn't like a puke situation but you
know just yeah unlike other VR headsets
there are no controllers so your eyes
are your cursor and your fingers are
like the mouse buttons to select things
you just pinch like this and then to
scroll you move it in different
directions
and yes one of the craziest things is
the front screen where people who look
at you can see your eyes
no I didn't test this but look at what
we made in Photoshop
okay so what do you do with it
during the demo I was able to scatter a
few apps in space so instead of having
multiple monitors you could just look at
these virtual screens around your room
I was also able to have a FaceTime chat
with an Apple employee except it wasn't
a video of her it was a 3D hologram of
her
during the call she was able to launch a
presentation for us to work together on
and the coolest thing was probably the
3D spatial photos and videos a dedicated
button on the top left of the headset
will allow wearers to snap these photos
though I couldn't try it myself and I
watched a 3D movie clip and was very
into it
do we need more things to do with the
Vision Pro especially to justify its 3
500 price tag
absolutely but that's why Apple's
getting it out now to developers so they
can dream up new experiences
are we all gonna buy this when it comes
out next year nope but this vision of
spatial Computing as Apple calls it and
seeing the digital in our real world
really does feel like the next big thing
even if it does seem at its present
moment a bit dystopian and isolating
and I do look forward to trying the
Vision Pro again and filming what's
actually happening instead of more of
this foreign
[Music]